jean-françois vigouroux bonjour vous
êtes le président des buralistes des
yvelines alors depuis le début de la
crise sanitaire les bureaux de tabac
font partie des rares commerces à avoir
été autorisé à rester ouverts bien sûr
en respectant les gestes barrière alors
quelle est la situation justement dans
les yvelines
notamment comment de bureaux sont restés
ouverts on n'a pas trop le chiffre le
chiffre mais bon on pense que il ya eu à
peu près 60% de tabac qui sont restés
ouverts
il ya eu un moment assez difficile qui a
été fin mars où on a eu le pic de
fermeture personnellement je suis resté
ouvert tout le temps et on a eu vraiment
beaucoup beaucoup d'affluence
pourquoi justement se pique de fermeture
ce que vous avez le nom le pic de
fermeture a dû
bien entendu à certains personne qui
était malade
certains buralistes qui était malade et
aussi par la peur de tomber malade et
parce que nous étions un commerce qui
avait la possibilité de rester ouverts
mais nous n'avions pas l'obligation de
rester ouvert il fallait bien sûr se
protéger et là était problème c'est que
quand quand tout est arrivé
malheureusement les plexiglas les gants
des masques
bon on en trouvait le prouveront
personnes si on n'avait pas été un peu
prévoyants
malheureusement on ne pouvait pas ouvrir
dans de bonnes conditions au niveau de
l'activité ce que vous avez constaté un
surplus d'activité depuis le début du
confinement
alors depuis en fait depuis l'annnonce
le 16 mars du confinement
on a eu un
un très gros pics de consommation qui
s'est étendu en plus d'un mois et en
fait on met ça aussi sur le dos du duc
ovide 19 parce que dans les yvelines
nous avons beaucoup de personnes qui
habitent et yves lainé qui vont
travailler sur paris et qui peuvent
acheter leur tabac sur paris étant
confiné dans les yvelines ils se sont
retrouvés à acheter leur tabac dans des
endroits où il acheté pas avant il ya ce
phénomène là le phénomène aussi que les
gens ne pouvaient pas se les procurer
par des par des amis qui pouvait aller à
l'étranger et aussi par la contrebande
est aussi parlé par internet
si certains pouvaient les recevoir par
la poste étant donné que tout ce qui
était colis c'était aussi saturé donc on
a retrouvé des clients qui n'avaient pas
l'habitude de venir chez nous tant
qu'ils ne connaissaient pas le prix
qu'ils connaissaient pas vraiment à
déterrer la dénomination du produit etc
donc nous attendons les chiffres de
logista qui devrait nous dire en
fonction des voiles et une sortie la
progression mais ce qui est certain
c'est que on a au moins une progression
de 25 à 30% sur les yvelines les
buralistes sont autorisés à vendre des
masques justement j'imagine que la
demande est forte
oui la demande est très forte au niveau
des masques on nous les demande tous les
jours nous en avons à vendre depuis
depuis la semaine dernière on nous
annonce que nous allons vendre des
masques
malheureusement la confédération a tout
mis en place pour se procurer des
masques auprès d'une entreprise
française de picardie dont des masques
100% français des masques lavables et
réutilisables 15 fois
malheureusement on est
on a été victime du succès car les deux
millions de masques ont été vendus en
auprès des buralistes en moins de 48
heures et après c'est la geôle
logistique pour fournir les buralistes
qui ne qui ne suit pas et donc nous
sommes toujours dans l'attenté de
recevoir les masques dans les jours qui
viennent ce sont des masters en tissu
c'est bien ça masque en tissu
réutilisables normes et afnor catégorie
2 donc
et je répète 100% français quand vous
parlez de deux millions c'est deux
millions pour pour les yvelines non 2
millions pour nom pour la la
confédération des buralistes pour les
24000 buralistes donc on pouvait en
acheter autant qu'on voulait mais bien
sûr ça va deux millions c'est un film il
aurait fallu si on en avait eu trois ou
quatre fois plus si on les a revendues
la même façon soit une dernière question
pour les masquer ce que vous limitez le
nombre de masques par par client
peut-être un ou deux par client ou pas
forcément sur le format c'est une
politique que j'ai avec la confédération
on favorise surtout les les artisans et
les commerçants qui en auraient besoin
pour fonctionner dans leur entreprise
donc afin de satisfaire sa nous avons
décidé de mettre la moitié de ce qu'on
va recevoir deux côtés pour la clientèle
pour les artisans les commerçants ce
qu'ils on servirait à titre
professionnel mais après nous avons des
gens qui qui peuvent nous en prendre
trois ou quatre voilà ça reste dans des
mesures bien sûr si un client vient nous
en demander d'ici on va on va pas lui et
lui dire gentiment qu' il vaut mieux en
acheter trois ou quatre épis fin en
avoir un peu plus ou moins merci et
jean-françois vigouroux en tout cas pour
toutes ces explications je rappelle que
vous êtes le président des buralistes
des yvelines
merci beaucoup excellente soirée et
prenez soin de vous